comment voyez-vous la rue sainte
catherine dans quelques années
c'est ce que veut savoir le maire de
montréal en tout cas il veut poser la
question aux citoyens ils vont pouvoir y
répondre à cette question lors de
consultations publiques sous peu on vise
2017 pour réaliser le projet à temps
pour le 375e anniversaire de montréal
jean-sébastien cloutier post a présenté
la vocation de la rue sainte catherine a
commencé à la fin du 19e siècle à
l'époque la rue résidentielle et la
population de la ville double tous les
15 ans des commerces décide de sortir du
vieux-montréal et de monter la cote pour
s'installer rue sainte catherine
un nouveau pôle commercial et n'est
favorisée par l'apparition du tramway
électrique
quelques années plus tard la rue vit ses
plus belles années les l'abbé eaton
simpson et compagnie attire les foules
autour du carré phillips mais la
concurrence est de plus en plus grande
et l'apparition des centres commerciaux
fait mal la rue sainte-catherine
commencent à souffrir
c'est sûr que les habitudes de marche de
magasinage ont changé il ya eu de la
négligence sur l'espace vert regard des
déclarations on n'arrête pas de percer
des trous ici et là par contre c'est
anne à quel point les gens ils sont très
attachés hélas trop tard peut-être une
façon de table et l'accès c'est
justement un trou involontaire celui là
qui a montré à quel point la
sainte-catherine avait besoin de
rénovations en août dernier la chaussée
s'est affaissée sous le poids de cette
rétrocaveuse en train d'exécuter des
travaux au coin de la rue guy la cause
une conduite d'égout plus que centenaire
est pleine de trous sous la
sainte-catherine au centre ville il
faudra donc la changer ce qui entraînera
d'énormes travaux
ce projet se creusent un trou peut
changer tuyaux c'est de desk ont pu
repenser la sainte catherine une
opportunité dit le maire alors qu'arrive
le 375e anniversaire de montréal
le plan de marche de la ville pour 2017
avoir remplacé les gauches sur une
distance de 670 mètres entre les rues
mansfield et bleury et en profiter pour
réaménager ce secteur la deuxième phase
1,7 km entre mansfield et atwater sera
réalisé plus tard
la ville lancera une consultation
publique cette année sur le
réaménagement de la rue sainte catherine
ce qui me séduit le plus présentement
c'est la seule idée de faire une
piétonnière ambitieux pour le
centre-ville donné la rue
sainte-catherine aux seuls piétons comme
l'était plus à l'est dans le village gai
bref complètement à l'opposé de ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui où l'automobiliste est
roi pour circuler et magazines et
l'urbaniste gérard beaudet pense plutôt
que la solution passe par un
élargissement des trottoirs
j'ai les réseaux une piétonnisation
complète on sait qu'à l'échelle
nord-américaine à une certaine époque
des années 60-70 hot 200 bus piétonniser
la majorité sont retournés à parts l
automobile
il sent que cette aide s'est déjà mise
en permanence une rup totana tétanise
ici regardez la largeur du trottoir
c'est pourrait pas d'oublier ça le
porte-parole d'héritage montréal pense
aussi qu interdire complètement les
voitures nuirait aux commerçants il
faudra réaménagé autrement dit nos bars
où ça passe par exemple par
l'élargissement des trottoirs
ça passe par de leur public ça passe par
des vitrines qui sont animés et des
espaces peut-être plus des gages à
certains endroits et quel genre de rue
voudrait les commerçants peut-être un
peu d'air à des arbres quelque chose
comme ça moi je vois plutôt comme le
prolongement de ceux qui ont fait du
quartier des spectacles
enfin dans l'enfant
l'ouest le tacle est vu comme un pavé un
peu comme sun je profite d'être plus
large mais gardez les autos jeu parfait
contentement leurs représentants
souhaite aussi qu'on diminue l'espace
réservé aux voitures sur la rue il faut
aussi dans ce réaménagement penser à
avoir de l'espace pour stationner pour
les voitures s'est pas desserrée sur rue
dans toutes les grandes villes
maintenant on a des stationnements
souterrains soit étages et denis coderre
est d'accord il faudra sûrement créer
plus d'espacés de stationnement ailleurs
au centre ville pour que son projet de
réaménagement se réalise
merci aux entreprises est actuellement
mais si on a une magnifique opportunité
puis on le fait dans les règles de la
consultation les fléchir ensemble qu'ils
trouvent une solution pour rehausser le
caractère commercial tout en faisant
quelque chose de design on peut parler
du mobilier urbain également pour parler
d'eux de créer un buzz montréal doit
mieux assumer son rôle nordique dit il
il imagine une rue sainte-catherine
chaleureuse à l'année avec des terrasses
et une illumination pour mettre en
valeur ces bâtiments patrimoniaux comme
l'édifice de la paix par exemple celui
de bugs ou cette ancienne banque coin
mansfield
on croit rêver il parle aussi une
question de ressources on doit rêver
pour n'est capable d'aller lever c'est
tout le monde travaille ensemble
alors jean sébastien on se souvient des
travaux d'envergure sur le boulevard
saint-laurent la cave est un cauchemar
pour les commerçants j'imagine que ceux
de la rue sainte-catherine craignent un
peu la même chose tout à fait avec
raison vous vous souvenez effectivement
de trois ans de travaux qui n'en
finissait plus de finir grosso modo de
2006 à 2008 les consultants les
commerçants ici avait été très peu
consultées ce sont des travaux qui
avaient été mal gérée à bien des égards
écouter une fois les travaux finis je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez qui
sommeille avait fallu recreuser pour
installer le gaz c'est même pas une
blague
et il y avait eu traîne un cauchemar
très peu de dédommagement taux
d'inoccupation des commerces sur
saint-laurent centre-ville avant les
travaux c'est grosso modo 3 % trois ans
plus tard 20 pour ça bon c'est pas la
presse la seule raison les travaux mais
ça donne un indice
et le pire c'est que vous promener
aujourd'hui sur saint laurent on voit à
peine qu'il ya eu des travaux majeurs
très peu de réaménagement d'amélioration
ici donc on l'est encore sur le coeur je
laisse écouter le porte parole des
commerçants du boulevard saint-laurent
mot déplorait médecin de famille c'est
un désastre monumental ce qui s'est
produit ici et je suis très heureux
d'apprendre qu'on annonce pour la rue
sainte catherine
je crois qu'avec une nouvelle mairie une
nouvelle administration peut-être qu'on
a les chances que ça se fasse
correctement les travaux qui sont prévus
c'est un mal nécessaire c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour la rue sainte catherine
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour montréal
et je dois admettre qu on est un peu
jaloux on est très heureux pour nos
collègues d'abord mais c'est sûr qu'on
va avoir une compétition féroce à la fin
des travaux s'ils sont bien exécutées
alors selon lui lorsqu'il ya des travaux
majeurs donc bien informé les
commerçants prévoir un plan de relance
est aussi des pénalités pour les
entrepreneurs qui ne respectent pas
leurs délais le maire denis coderre nous
assurer que la ville travaille main dans
la main du début à la fin avec ses
commerçants et qu'il y aurait des
mesures d'atténuation pour les impacts
des travaux bref d'ici 2017 probablement
premier réaménagement entre bleury et
mansfield
merci beaucoup jean-sébastien bonne
facture et un au revoir au revoir